someone asks you to give the definition
of story what is the answer you always
give
oh wow
um
uh compelling narrative with a beginning
middle and an end
Maybe
his story is still King
I think so yeah yeah I say that on my
website right stories yeah I think so
um I was just listening to
an interview with Stephen Soderberg
today and he said for him his main
litmus test is he has to hear about the
story or read a script and say hell yeah
he has to have the feeling that if he
were to direct this
it's a hell yeah for him so you know
that story your concept your pitch your
log line it has to
make people say oh wow I really want to
see that you know hell yeah that sounds
like a really good show or movie
you think we've gotten away from that
because now we have so many great visual
effects and different things we can add
in that we've lost sight of that hell
yeah feeling
I think in some ways I think the big
thing is that too many cliches are
constantly put on screen in film and TV
especially TV because there's so many
shows there's so many streaming networks
and so I think they are hiring
filmmakers who maybe don't respect story
as much don't have as much experience
with screenwriting and story
and their first move is to move
something to the nearest cliche you know
like uh at actor in in a tent scene
saying this ends now you know it's like
how many times have you heard that line
you know
but first time writers might write that
that was actually our next question so I
like that in terms of the dialogue that
sounds very cliche what about in terms
of an actual story of you know whether
it's a rom-com or a crime you know
procedural what is sort of cliche that
we keep seeing over and over again
well I mean
um I think every genre has its cliche
elements or beats you know the rom-com
has the meat cute
and you know I feel like you note I
don't know if it's that I know it's
coming or just that they make it that
much more obvious now in movies and TV
the meat cute it becomes more of a thing
because it's kind of a term that's
entered the parlance
um but it's hard to make it unique and
original that meet cute moment between
the two soon-to-be lovers
so you know it's hard it's it's uh if it
was on the page and you're submitting a
script you would want to come up with a
unique way to do that not just another
cliche way of you know them bumping into
each other on the street or the one of
them is an architect and they're holding
their model of the building and the
other guy the other person comes and
smashes into them and it smashes the
whole thing and oh my gosh you're a jerk
he ran into me but we all know in an
hour and a half we're gonna be kissing
you know
so it's some of it is cliche but then
some of it is necessary that we expect
that in that type of a in a rom-com we
expect yeah something someone took
someone's order as a a coffee shop and
then they're fighting over it and then
the next thing you know they're running
into each other later and yeah yeah so
there are there's genre tropes which you
want to have you just have to find a
unique way to fulfill those genre tropes
you know
um
horror film now there's so many jump
scares right and every kind of uh new
low budget horror movie I see there's
the person in the mirror you know when
they they open the mirror and they get
their pills or whatever and they close
the mirror and then there's a psycho
behind them in the reflection and yeah
it's an effective jump scare uh you know
technique but there's probably you can
probably get around it you probably
don't quite need that exact shot or
somehow
uh don't Telegraph it too much so the
audience doesn't know it's coming you
know I mean that's a challenge of a
horror film it's like how do you scare
people when we know the conventions of
horror movies and that's what's gonna
make your script or your movie Stand Out
and then in action what would some of
the the how do you make your tropes not
become cliche let's say for action or
drama
well I you definitely still want to use
uh the story map beat sheet or you know
um find a beat sheet that works for you
so you still gonna hit those signpost
markers no matter what the genre is
but an action movie I mean
I don't know I uh you just gotta find
interesting ways for like
um the first appearance of the villain
for to create tension and uh ticking
time clock it's great to insert a
ticking time clock at the midpoint or
maybe end of act two so find a unique
way to have basically a countdown to the
ultimate consequences you know so how do
you create the stakes and the
consequences that's going to distinguish
you as a writer
okay so some of that you need to have
that tension in there but then if if the
if the hero is kicking down the door and
then two people are bound and gagged and
I mean that that's
sort of very unconventional yeah right
so so maybe you can find a more unique
way around that I don't know sure
interesting where do most writers go
wrong with story
ah well there's a lot of ways to go
wrong on the page with the screenplay
um for me I see a lot of uh too dense
description just too much description
um I see a lot of explaining in
description if you're explaining what
we're seeing
it's not as good as if you're just
showing us what we're seeing on the page
so if you say you know Tom Cruise
crosses the street
that's showing
if you say Tom Cruise
thinks about whether to talk to cross
the street for a second then he sees a
red car coming and he decides he's gonna
run and try to beat the car right you're
explaining the motivations of the
character you don't want to do that I
don't know why it just doesn't work on
the page show don't tell is like the
biggest Rule still applies it doesn't
matter how many years of filmmaking we
have
it just still applies
so I see that a lot
I see
um just scripts that are dragged on too
long especially like the Final Act
a lot of back and forth I say a lot of
just keep it simple keep it simple
stupid uh find the focus you know you
don't need so much plotting if we really
care about the character and they're
pursuing their goal against obstacles
and all of that is compelling and
interesting and we're rooting for them
you don't need a 40 page act 3 with
constant reversals and
tons of plotting happening which I think
is actually one of the problems with a
lot of modern films especially action
movies they just go on and on and on and
they're repetitive you know like
how many car chases can you have in one
film and we've seen you know car chases
for 100 years you know the recent
Indiana Jones I think it had at least
one too many car chases
um it just if it feels repetitive it
feels like you've already seen it in
that script before
cut it and find another way to advance
the story
do you think that's because like a lot
of these focus groups the the people say
I love this car chase and then all right
guys we got to put more car chases in
put two more in I don't well I think a
lot of it is now they must be giving
directors Final Cut more than they used
to I think
because there's so many really long
films I mean there's so many two and a
half hour movies there's so many almost
three hour movies
and I don't know anyone who's like I
want my movie to be three hours you know
but I think because
they're all of the companies streamers
Studios networks they're trying to hire
those well-known auteur directors you
know get a name director because then
they can get the budget and they can get
the cast and everything and that's great
they're talented
but I think there maybe kowtowing too
much to them and saying you just deliver
us the film you want to deliver because
two hours and 43 minutes might be too
long you know for that story
now I just want re-watch Boyhood and I
love it and I know some people said it's
too long but for me that worked but I
get it it was over many years that they
did it so you could see character
changes but yeah another thing that I
like that people don't is is voice over
narration of the protagonist I know
that's kind of a No-No can you explain
why that is for me I feel like when I
see it it's covering up a lot of uh what
could be just shown not told uh
information and what could just be pure
good storytelling it's usually
because they want to explain something
and like I said you want to show don't
tell you don't want to explain so if you
have to explain something in your story
well then you might need to change it
because it's not clear enough to the
reader
and you don't want to use voiceover as
just too much of a crutch to fill in
story problems it can work but I see a
lot of newer writers using it when they
really don't need to I think